bonsoir bienvenue en basse normandie au
village des jeux équestres mondiaux au
parc des expositions de caen deuxième
jour de compétition et regarder tout de
suite ces images du premier podium de
ses 7e jeux équestres le podium du
dressage par équipes bonsoir florent
turpin je sois bien en dressage d'être
disciplinés à la base de toutes les
disciplines s'est classé comme en
football à la fin c'est l'allemagne qui
gagne oui les allemands et les
britanniques grand favori de ces jeux
équestres mondiaux qui brille déjà dans
la compétition une deuxième journée avec
une météo et oui assez clémente il a
même parfois fait beau sur les sites de
compétition presque pas de pluie mais
plein de belles images emilie et léo
grâce à total va revenir dans un instant
mais d'abord un coup d'oeil sur le reste
de l'actualité c'est d'abord la
composition du nouveau gouvernement de
manuel valls et bien bernard cazeneuve
l'ancien maire de charlesbourg reste au
ministère de l'intérieur autre
information importante que la
réouverture du pont mathilde à rouen
pour le plus grand soulagement des
automobilistes qui veulent emprunter
depuis 17 heures cet après midi il avait
fermé en octobre 2012 et un très
important incendie il avait donc été
fermé pendant 22 mois allez retourne
quant aux jeux équestres mondiaux
florent que s'est il passé en dressage
on a vu le sacre de l'allemagne par
équipes mais quand on regarde les
performances des français on est un peu
déçu oui journée mitigée pour l'équipe
de france de dressage au stade d'ornano
mais c'est pourtant une cavalière au nom
très français qui a brillé aujourd'hui
vous la voyez elle s'appelle charlotte
du jardin à la 29 ans elle est jolie et
c'est la grande star mondiale de la
discipline sans surprise la cavalière
britannique a pris cet après-midi la
tête du classement provisoire sur son
cheval pas les gros hits only passage
également 7 à près du français arnaud
serre que l'on va voir ici à l'image le
français sous l'ovation des 8000
spectateurs du stade dans maman s'est
classé 20e en poche et jessica michel
l'autre grand espoir de l'équipe de
france s'est quant à elle totalement
manqué elle n'est pas qualifiée pour le
grand prix spécial qui va unir les 30
meilleurs cavaliers de premier tour je
vous propose de l'écouter jessica michel
micro de corinne vie en rose à
jessica méchas les notes autour de 68
comment vous avez senti votre jugement
alors elle était vraiment génial et j'ai
adoré monter dans cette arène affectant
de public français être acclamé comme ça
à l'entée chance cela n'arrive qu'en
france ou alors on est dans les trois
meilleurs mondiaux et c'était vraiment
génial j'ai vraiment tout donné elle a
tout donné aussi
malheureusement on n'est pas parfait et
ça on le sait
je serais très très content de l'arrêter
alors il ya deux ans aux yeux de nombre
vous étiez là la seule française
aujourd'hui il ya une véritable équipe
de dressage en france ça change vraiment
les choses à bas la pression est
répartie sur quatre cavaliers au lieu
que ce soit sur un cavalier alors
forcément c'est mieux on peut se suivre
venir se voir on est plusieurs à avoir
la même épreuve et ça c'est très sympa
oui andré jacquot bill vous êtes notre
consultant parce qu'aussi le speaker de
cso la semaine prochaine est-ce que moi
parler de contre performance pour
jessica michel par rapport à ce qu'on
aurait souhaité rêvait peut-être un
petit peu trop rêver peut-être mais si
on garde tous ses résultats en grand
prix depuis depuis deux ans hormis les
jeux de londres où elle sort à 70% et
encore les 31e donc aller par un grand
prix spécial elle est toujours à 40,60
cheval là on est on est sûr c'est sur
ces points faibles il commence elle
commence une magnifique est monté
jusqu'à 75% et quand ses points faibles
sont arrivés la transition passagers le
piaf et dont un assez joli pour eux doit
être faite voilà ça c'est le passage pas
le sait pas s'en passer ses allures
préféré et ça s'est bien passé
aujourd'hui donc on va faire un plan
physique à michel qui monte est une
jument allemande une oldenburg arrinera
de us il faut savoir qu'en dressage et
bien deux écoles s'affrontent depuis
toujours l'école allemande hollandaise
et l'école ibérique et les choses sont
en train de changer korinor et oui petit
à petit donc 2 école de dressage est
depuis longtemps une suprématie presque
totale grâce landaise et allemandes vous
allez voir sur ces images un cheval
hollandais ce sont des grands choix
c'est aérien souvent des robes foncé des
chevaux qui ont beaucoup d'amplitude
dans les mouvements qui montrait aux
leur dos vous le voyez encore là sur
cette entrée sur la carrière et puis
donc en france eh bien les chevaux
ibériques portugais ou espagnols comme
ceux que l'on retrouve dans les corridas
grille plus petits avec une encolure
plus large qui monte les jeunes ou
beaucoup plus haut vous voyez dans cette
allure qu'on appelle le passage mais qui
ont moins d'amplitude dans leurs
mouvements vous allez encore le voir là
sur ces changements de pied
donc ces chevaux ibériques sont moins
bien noté un juge mais ils sont en train
de rattraper leur retard et on a vu ici
une très très bonne équipe espagnole une
petite toute petite révolution dans le
milieu très fermé du dressage mais merci
corinne florence et est aujourd'hui
également la deuxième journée du para
dressage mais c'était à l'hippodrome de
caen on valoir devant des tribunes
encore bien ce matin il faut le dire en
para dressage des cavaliers on le sait
sont handicapés sont répartis en grade
selon l'importance de leur handicap
ce matin passe aux cavaliers gr4 à
bouillargues ici à l'image la cavalière
française n'a visé qui après un très bon
passage s'est emparé de la sixième place
du classement provisoire est avec nous
sur ce bateau valérie salese bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
cavalière de parra très sage grade 1 b c
à vous est paraplégique
on vous a vu concourir hier alors que
c'est une mode par équipes vous l'avez
fait pour tester la piste c'est ce que
font la plupart des cavaliers sont la
plupart des cavaliers aujourd'hui nous
sommes tous partants sur la première
épreuve qu'elle soit par team test aux
parts individuelles pour notre propre
participation alors ça fait seulement
sept mois que vous avez votre jumeau
dimon du loup en france est depuis sept
mois c'est peu c'est très peu c'est très
court
malheureusement il nous faudrait
quelques mois de plus pour se dire qu'on
est au top mais voilà je suis au top et
je suis là donc
quoi dire de plus c'est vraiment galéré
comme on peut le dire autrement on
pouvait avoir un cheval et c'est souvent
le cas on parlera dressage j'ai beaucoup
galéré c'est souvent le cas puisque
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a quand même
beaucoup de cavaliers dans le thibault
stoclin dont la dîmière vinchant moi
même qui la télé me disais qu'ils aient
vent des nouveaux chevaux tout juste
cette année donc en galère parce que
c'est dur de convaincre des pauvres
guetta c'est dur d'en trouver c'est dur
de les convaincre de coûts conjuguées de
nous louer les chevaux afin de pouvoir
faire du part adressé à haut niveau
marc dans une structure qui est
l'institut français du cheval du fce qui
apporte son soutien avec également une
logistique on est encore très forte
tension mais les autres fédérations les
britanniques bien évidemment largement
en avance ou des chevaux qui ont cru en
prime time ce qu'on vient de voir et que
avec que jessica tout à leurs biens
ensuite parce et deviennent des légendes
par exemple de cavaliers paraplégique
comme valérie mais on a encore beaucoup
de retard oui il ya la mobilisation sur
facebook et avec nos confrères d'equidia
concept nouveau passage à blandy diamond
du loing votre parcours vous êtes eu une
ancienne cavalière d'obstacles jeu et de
plats oui vous avez fait une chute qui
vous a handicapé et six mois après vous
être monté à cheval
c'est le cas de la plupart des cas vite
par dressage il ne rejette pas le cheval
pour autant non je pense que la mort du
cheval quand elle est là on la tient
quoi ça c'est resté dans nos coeurs et
ça reste ma passion je pense à vie quoi
qu'il arrive c'est vrai que la plupart
de nous dans la compétition et dans
l'équipe de france on est tous revenu
sur sur le cheval et ça nous apporte
énormément donc bien sûr on est tous là
merci beaucoup à lire ici dalle on
poussera à vous demain matin on croise
les doigts râle aussi grâce à florent
regarde maintenant ce qu'a donné ce
deuxième jour de compétition cette fois
ci en ruines mais les épreuves de
reining qui se déroule au parc des
expositions ambiance rodéo et western et
commis hier défi du passé
impressionnante grosse déception en
revanche pour le français franck perrais
numéro un mondial victime on va dire ça
comme ça d'une ruade de son cheval sur
un changement de direction on va l'avoir
encore mieux sur cette image ça n'a
l'air de rien mais ça lui a coûté très
cher au classement puisqu'il n'est que
75 yens en revanche belle satisfaction
pour un p'tit normand le voilà ce matin
il s'appelle bastien bourgeois il habite
à bellengreville dans le calvados il
termine dans les 40 premiers c'est
vraiment pas mal écouté le c'était aux
micros de france baby ici voilà on est
en france les trois quarts du des
gradins en fera des français
effectivement ils attendent donc
des savoirs
voilà comme j'ai dit je suis un peu déçu
du score où ça va pas forcément et est
ce que j'attendais japonais un petit peu
plus voilà les jugeons pas crédité ces
voix-là savons disait c'est du haut
niveau là c'est dur d'aller chercher des
points andré-jacques le coup de cul la
ruade du cheval de franck perrais c'est
surprenant on voit plutôt sain en saut
d'obstacles morning de joie ou de la
discipline
je crois je regardais encore une fois
c'est vrai que la transition pour
ralentir parce que là ils vont très très
dense hier et puis il faut repasser car
le travail me semble-t-il c'est vrai
qu'il a fait un petit peu je juge pas
est ce que c'est ça qui n'a pas aimé ou
alors est-ce que ça peut être une juste
une douleur sur le dos ou le glisse un
petit peu par un parent sliding crise a
peut-être une leurs édiles rudy mais par
contre se sont créés par les juges
immédiatement
allez on sort des résultats un moment
pour s'intéresser au bien-être de ces
sportifs de très haut niveau que sont
les chevaux que l'on voit ici où josé
casse mondiaux 170 vétérinaires sont
mobilisés pendant ces jeux une sur tous
les sites des cliniques et des
laboratoires ont été installés en
obtenant l'or noir a du pain keira à
partir de jeudi le propos complet à des
leds céchi triqueneaux
bord de mer sur la plage et avec le
sable et les guette à tout petit la
méditation sur la peau à quelques jours
du concours complet la moindre blessure
est prise très au sérieux par le
vétérinaire de l'équipe
il m'a fait une occase j'ai un petit peu
leur médecin de famille je les connais
très bien les ai suivis tout au long de
la saison je les ai vus en compétition
j'ai participé au stage de préparation à
la sélection en tout 35 vétérinaires
seront sur le site au moment des
épreuves une clinique a été installé
pour gérer les chevaux malades ou
blessés on a une boxe
qui permettent aux vétérinaires des fip
de traiter leurs chevaux on a toute une
série de bureaux pour les vétérinaires
on à la pharmacie
on peut tous traités on va dire les
premières urgences et puis dès que ça va
devenir un petit peu compliqué que
nécessitant beaucoup de médicaments ou
en tout cas des moyens d'être un peu
plus important que ce qu'on a ici c'est
évacuer référés vers des cliniques
extérieur pour que rien ne vienne
perturber les jeux équestres les
vétérinaires tube la santé des chevaux
très près dès leur arrivée un premier
examen est réalisée pour évaluer l'état
général de l'animal fréquence cardiaque
vaccination température endroits pollués
et vérifiés comme pour les athlètes de
haut niveau diagnostics doivent pouvoir
être fait au plus vite sur le site un
laboratoire et opérationnel 24 heures
sur 24 on va frotter un peu la muqueuse
nasale du cheval j'accueille quelques
quelques cellules et les éventuels les
sports tous les agents pathogènes qui
pourrait le cheval pour moi l'objectif
détecter les animaux malades pour éviter
toute contamination
au total 170 btr sont mobilisés pour ces
jeux équestres sur les différents sites
andré-jacques pour qu'autant de soins
finalement n'apporte plus de soins aux
chevaux cavaliers je crois qu'il ya un
an déjà il faut saluer le nombre
incroyable de vétérinaires bénévoles qui
sont regroupés pour fabriquer un vrai
commando pour ce pot soigner les chevaux
veiller sur les chevaux il ya des
chevaux qui vient du monde entier qui
voyait jouer que les virus ça peut
voyager aussi donc ils sont là pour
éviter que ça se propage pour leur
sécurité et puis après il ya le
vétérinaire qui occupait vraiment des
athlètes donc veiller que tout aille
bien jusqu'à la fin de la compétition il
ya aussi des vétérinaires qui sont là
pour les contrôles antidopage donc ils
sont effectivement surveiller au
millimètre du jour et mettre le pied sur
le site jusqu'au jo ou partent
agile mais c'est là vous voyez enfin je
pense qu'il va vous émerveiller encore
pendants
pendant ces deux semaines et athlète de
très très haut niveau et il parle pas
donc il faut essayer de voir à sa place
ce qui va ou ce qui va pas
prendre la température du cheval pour
savoir si un petit problème ou pas voilà
alors on va maintenant retrouver hélène
jacques dans le village des jeux avec le
syndicat national des éleveurs de cob
normand l'autre cheval de trait de chez
nous moins connus le percheron mais qui
gagne est reconnue ln oui bonsoir à midi
bonsoir à tous je suis avec norbert
coulon un des ambassadeurs un du cob
normand le coach est à l'honneur pendant
ces gemmes alors il j'ai envie de dire
pourquoi il faut promouvoir cette phrase
mal voir parce que la plaine qualité et
que c'est une race classe est menacée on
peut l'utiliser à des fins montée ou
bien appeler comme aujourd'hui c'est une
race très légère qu'un plein d'aptitude
en plein d'avenir et pourtant pourtant
il ya manque de naissance et un petit
oui oui là-bas depuis quelques années on
s'aperçoit que le nombre de naissances a
sérieusement diminué on est passé de 600
à 200 en l'espace de cinq ans
la majorité des éleveurs sont très âgés
donc les juments disparaissent avec la
avec les éleveurs il ya très peu de
jeunes qui reprennent l'activité on se
dit da vous êtes-vous champion de france
d'attelage de cob normand vous étiez
deux thèmes la coupe du monde pourquoi
on les retrouve pas au jeu séquestre
mondiaux
mais ils font pas partie de la même
famille à la famille des chevaux traits
et je faut 200 sont des aptitudes
différentes
mais les jeux mondiaux de choses alors
ya une initiative intéressante pendant
ces jeux zik est ici au village vous
parrainez un poulain étoile filante oui
étoiles ça allait donner l'occasion aux
gens qu'on n'a pas les moyens d'avoir un
cheval de suivre en direct l'évolution
et le développement de la pouliche sur
internet sur le site du san et les gens
peuvent donner ce qu'ils veulent et puis
se rendre au stand main du coach normand
sur l'espèce normand pour en avoir un
peu plus de renseignements tous les
jours il ya des balades voilà d'attelage
on peut vous retrouver ici dans le
village merci à vous ok merci à vous
merci à tous les deux il y avait un peu
plus de monde aujourd'hui dans le
village des cheveux puisqu'il n'a pas
plu plus de monde également dans les
tribunes plus de spectateurs sur les
lieux de compétition et beaucoup de
familles car l'équitation est un sport
hautement transmissible voyez le
reportage de stéphanie le ray de cyril
duponchel d'el feel zoé et lola devrait
être bien placé pour admirer le dressage
elle est spontanée de rambouillet pour
partager son avis pourquoi venir en
famille parce que c'est rare un ciment
c'est tous les quatre ans les jeux c'est
en france donc je pense qu'il faut aussi
encourager la discipline et puis leur
montrait un beau spectacle dans le stade
d'ornano la compétition a déjà commencé
sous le regard attentif de spectateurs
de tous horizons être ici en normandie à
vivre l'évènement à 4 ans ans pour cette
famille de souris
et dont les voiliers prennent
quelques mètres plus loin on retrouve
delphine c'est bien fait mais chaney
ralenti il a du mal
à eelv on s'aperçut rarement la
difficulté technique aussi du nom ça
reste un choix non c'est pas un vélo
bon ben voilà il ya des choux
c'est super élégant de certains jours
quand et six matches peut-être que je
fume ça un peu moins amusant que le
sommet
quand on regarde ses chances à super g
si certains sont plus dissipés d'autres
petits ont bien conscience de la
difficulté du dressage et je pense que
si un jour je vais y arriver
moi toute ma vie à la sortie du stade la
discipline n'a peut être pas quand il
tout le public est ce que tu aimerais
faire comme les cavaliers
mais ce n'est peut-être une question
d'âge les jeunes prévenus parmi les plus
jeunes
emmanuel chauny 1 vous à recoller encore
un cancer pour commencer avec le permet
les photos de l'enfant s'engage avec le
goût de plus important que le poney
franchement avec un tout petit poney 1
falbala 90 centimes valeur c'est
pourquoi je n'arriverai jamais à
prononcer par les deux bouts rida de
petit-bourg ita j'avais pas bien le dire
ces images des petits bouts rudaz voilà
on appelle communément la fantasia
monsieur thibout reid est un sport
équestre vous m'aimez deslandres et j'ai
accepté les sports équestres
traditionnels marocains en démonstration
c'est en milieu de journée dans le
village des jeux le casino type de
mettre à l'honneur le bar de marocains
petit cheval très endurant comment on
dire de l'ajac la
poule i am le t on le un peu comme à la
corse mais dans l'autre et c'est une
vraie discipline sportive reconnue à la
fédération royale marocaine des sports
aux pièces avec des dizaines et des
dizaines d' équipes en compétition à
grand semaine du cheval il faut qu'ils
doublent tous très très aligner les
costumes là toute la chorégraphie le
moment où ils tirent tous ensemble qui
est assez impressionnant faut que ce
soit vraiment ensemble la façon dont ils
vont s'arrête au galop maintenant je
sais c'est vraiment ça partait de deux
jeux de village en fait toute une
tradition et c'est devenu au maroc une
discipline sportive voilà donc pourquoi
pas aux jeux mondiaux un jour peut-être
en 2072 florent geel qui nous attend
demain rendez-vous demain d2 dès 9
heures au stade michel d'ornano pour le
grand prix spécial de dressage qui va
réunir donc les 30 meilleurs cavaliers à
l'issue du premier tour et puis toujours
à 9 heures début de la troisième journée
de compétition de parra dressage à
l'hippodrome de caen valerio morcourt
d'hommes 1 demain matin après midi
l'après midi en sera samedi peu plus
tard après tirage au sort voilà aussi
qu'on espère parce que
tout chez intel du chien si oui vous
donnera le résultat de nos spas de
valérie salesse jeudi ce sera l'épreuve
d'endurance dans la baie du
mont-saint-michel 160 km en plusieurs
boucles autour de sartilly
70 je vous ai cavaliers vont y
participer ce devrait être aux
spectacles plus de 5000 spectateurs sont
attendus alors si vous voulez y aller
que faut-il savoir éléments de réponse
avec stéphanie vino et voilà marc
l'endurance c'est un circuit de 160
kilomètres répartis en cinq parcours
pour les gens qui ont acheté un billet
il est conseillé arrivée sur le site de
sortie dès 6 heures du matin pour
assister au départ vers 7 heures sans
billets il suffit de se positionner sur
le bord de la route cet endroit avec des
parkings ont été tout spécialement
préparé pour accueillir le public en a
imaginé trois dispositifs pour les
spectateurs qui peuvent se rendre sur
les plages de jullouville de kairon de
carole de dragey à fin d'année par la
course à des heures bien précises
puisque les passages ont été communiqués
ils pourraient avoir les détails des
boucles et des horaires de passage il
suffit de se rendre sur le site internet
des jeux équestres mondiaux en voiture
le circuit est libre d'accès la seule
contrainte de circulation ce jour là
sera l'axé granville avranches qui sera
coupé de 7h à 10h au niveau de saint
pierre langers la première boucle
emprunté par les concurrents sectionne
le rd 973 au niveau de la commune de
saint pierre langers donc là on est
obligés d'interrompre totalement la
circulation dans les deux sens pendant
le passage des chevaux qui s'effectue en
deux phases une phase aller une phase
retour il est donc conseillé aux
automobilistes qui ferait avranches
granville ou versement de passer par là
enel pour éviter le secteur
et vous pouvez retrouver toutes ces
informations sur notre site internet et
notamment le plan d'accès 1 pour la
sortie voir cette épreuve d'endurance
sur notre site bastien normandie point
france 3 point fr notre chronique
quotidienne les pieds dans le crottin ou
les jeux équestres mondiaux par le petit
bout de la lorgnette ce soir d'aller
voir mathieu binningen ne recule devant
aucun sacrifice
alors impossible d'y échapper la ville
de caen affiches partout les jeux
équestres alors village des jeux 10 min
à pied on va tester pour vous est ce
qu'il ya vraiment dit me sépare
après on est là
premier souci bas
je marche d'une bonne allure on va dire
balade est pas mal bref des gens ou jour
là et le spi that cinq minutes 50
secondes et j'aperçois novillade
2030 en profite lorsqu'alain ça
commence à devenir chaud la fin du
parcours entre minutes 10 secondes
maintenant
thaler on a tenu un patois est un
village à 5
minutes à une minute
emma qui trichent là qui prennent un peu
loose aller je le faire aussi en fuite
d'eau dieu bénisse que la vendange voilà
douze minutes 18 secondes et sept
centièmes c'est le temps exact pour
refaire ses 10 minutes puis a trop mal
parcours
mathieu bling n en testeurs de des
parcours village des jeux emmanuel
chaunu willy donc ça y est le nouveau
gouvernement valse 2 est constituée
alors regardez notre dresseur en chef
vient de l'irl a rassemblé son écurie
bon il ya trop de changements il n'y a
pas une seule oreille qui bouge et il va
quand même réussi une chose incroyable
c'est qu'il va aussi réussir à faire
plier le président de la république je
pense parce que c'est un excellent
dresseur cci il en sait quelle race de
cheval la balle là ou pas pourra ni à
poney
non je n'accorde aucune comme de teckel
voilà elle regarde des saisies ces
images c'est plutôt étonnante de
l'hippodrome de la prairie à la fin du
dix neuvième siècle alors halte à 2876
images mais sachez qu'il ya exactement
cent soixante dix sept ans avait lieu la
première course sur l'hippodrome de la
prairie le 26 août 18h37 voilà
voilà pour tous et l'essentiel de ce
qu'il faut savoir cette deuxième journée
déjà sur notre site internet dans le
soir 3 et autour de 23 heures demain
midi gros plan sur l'endurance on en
reparle demain soir bonne chose valérie
thales merci et à demain les gars
rincon et à
belles demeures bourgeoises pour faire
une halte avant de repartir c'était tout
à fait ce qu'il nous fallait avec trois
autres officiers on a décidé d'y passer
d'amis de ce côté là de la scène on
était en coaching
en plus des filles de la maison
fritz a fait venir la ravissante
marguerite dont ils veulent faire
connaissance au café du village
après l'enfer convenait de livres la
sortie de chambois